well january i guess has a reputation
for having an increase in divorces and
evidently this is the time when many
married couples consider calling it
quits yeah apparently some experts say
tensions over the holidays play a role
and certainly the pandemic hasn't helped
hector mejia reporting live hector you
talked with the therapist about this
whole thing what are they what are they
telling you
yeah well she tells us they're also
seeing an increase in domestic violence
and when it comes to divorces dr
catherine hartline says it's something
an individual has likely been thinking
about for
about a full year before the other
person knows about it the unlv couple
and family therapy professor says it's
something that doesn't come up just out
of the holidays but many wait for them
to be over to carry through with their
decision dr hertlein also notes an
increase in domestic violence right now
during the pandemic
you've got to recognize the science of
intimate partner violence so often we
see little subtle signs of it and we
sort of dismiss them as being someone's
having a bad day or well they didn't
physically hit me so you know intimate
partner violence is a lot of things it's
emotional it's intellectual it's sexual
and it can be physical
if you are thinking about a breakup she
recommends to first slow things down and
think about looking to a professional
for couples counseling she also says
make sure you have the support that you
need and we've also learned that local
attorneys are also busy with questions
about divorces one local attorney told
us that he's seeing between 30 and 40
percent more phone calls people calling
their office asking about the divorce
process reporting live hector mejia live
local now